Uh my name is Isan. I'm Muslim and I'm
an employee at the limited company. I'm
a big fan of yours. Uh actually
>> employee employee of
>> in uh at the limited comm company.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And then I have a question in your
talk. Why do you call prophet Issa peace
be upon him to Jesus Christ peace be
upon him? What does the Chris mean
according to dictionary and what
Christian think it means? Are we Muslim
allowed to call prophet Issa as Jesus
Christ because we believe we he wasn't
crucified and he isn't a god?
>> The question that why do we say peace be
upon him after the name of Jesus or
Isaam? Why
>> uh sorry uh why do you call in your talk
prophet Issa is as uh Jesus Christ
>> with Jesus Christ Jesus Christ with the
prophet Issa
>> the brothers asked the question why in
my talk do I call Isaam as Jesus Christ
is the question
>> yeah and what does the mean in what does
Christ mean
>> in the right Arabic word is isa Ah
in their language they have a
habitualized like how we say Jonas they
say Jonah they add J to it. So the
correct name is Yonah Jonas Alisam they
make it J and Jonah. So same like Issa
they make Jesus.
Christ means to rub to anoint.
The Greek word Christ means to anoint.
When you make someone as the king, you
anoint him, you rob him and make him
that. The same is used in the Quran.
The Quran refers to as Isa
and Ibenariam, the son of Mary. So this
is again
Christ is a word which means to anoint.
I'm saying this so that the Christians
they recognize who I'm talking about. So
in the Christian Bible who they call
Jesus Christ the one anointed is the
same what is in the Quran Isaam.
Now we as Muslims whenever we take the
name of any messenger we have to say
Salam compulsory
especially a religious person. A normal
Muslim doesn't say it is mustab or
sunnah but a religious person has to say
that we have to respect them. So that is
the reason I say the translation of
Salam in English is peace be upon him.
So we respect Jesus peace be upon him
more than the Christian themselves. Hope
that answers the question.
>> Okay. Thank you sir.